obviously this look this move looks
pretty pathetic because tsipras is
desperate to pay off the international
creditors but what would how do you
respond to that he had no other choice
but to take the money from you well
anyway you you know we would like to
help the government and we have a moral
obligation to do so but there should
have been a previous consultation on
that the deliberation so in order if we
we are to hand out our cash reserve we
should know we should have more
information we should know what's going
on up your famously nonpartisan if you
think that Tsaritsa and suppresses
government are not going to be able to
cut a deal with the troika why not come
out and publicly oppose them why not get
political about this now actually our
country now is in negotiation and the
problem of Greece always has been that
even in fundamental fundamental issues
we have not arrived to a certain degree
of national unity so we have to back up
the government but at the same time the
government must keep in mind that eighty
percent of the Greek population wants to
stay in Europe and remain in the
eurozone so that is the most essential
we had a national unity on the target of
remaining in the euro and the government
must take it at their very very serious
consideration mayor you have joined
citizenship you were born in New York I
want you to speak to the American people
but particularly the EU leaders right
now you are in the trenches of this
crisis with your tenure of five years
what is your message to the Germans at
Brendan Greely speaks to or the
Americans watching this show about the
will of the Greek people not the fancy
guys in suits and ties or suits and no
ties what's the will of the Greek people
this April they told you it's very very
clear the message is very clear we have
here a people that has suffered for five
years and we have an unemployment rate
of almost thirty percent sixty percent
among young people so people have
suffered it's it's true that the reforms
that should have been done have remained
in you know in
Midway till to the end of that we should
pursue we should continue with reforms
but Greek people and that is a very
clear message I can assure you we want
to remain in Europe we are at the core
of the European Union we're going
through a very severe I a new government
after the ballet rigolette finishes your
nation have a new government no no no no
we have already had elections we cannot
change government every day so what we
need is that the government takes under
consideration this will of the people
but at the same time European leaders
must think of the people that has
suffered for five years with the
problems that i just mentioned to you
think of the unemployment that the
economic crisis I want to talk a little
bit about that suffering in Athens as
the people in your Athens watch these
talks you say they want to stay in the
EU do they watch TV you know the
comments coming out of Riga with hope or
with despair well they are with with
skepticism with skepticism think about
this people I come to the same issue now
five years suffering and they still
remain calm imagine what could have rite
aid in other societies well with the
unemployment rate that I just mentioned
dr. neal get a questionnaire shannon
real from CFR for the mayor please what
can you do from a local level to help
the federal government achieve this
achieve some sort of negotiation or stay
in the euro in the local government we
have a mandate of five years we are a
you know a center of gravity there for
the political system and what we are
trying to do is to show how things
should have been done we're making our
economies we are helping poor people and
we'll try to foster economy and are you
making your ship in essence are you
making preparations for a default though
if we don't get a deal no no no no there
are no preparations for default default
is the chaos yeah so we are not
preparing the chaos now now we are
confident we are trying very hard we are
optimistic and I think that finally
Greece will arrive to a compromise with
our with our creditors I mean in Europe